bonjour jean marc qui devra gagner mais
qu'est ce qui se passe alors est ce
qu'on écrit de plus en plus mal est-ce
qu'on a on fait de plus en plus de
fautes mais à côté faut d'abord préciser
que l'étude à laquelle vous faites
allusion a été commandée par le projet
voltaire est un centre de formation à
l'orthographe il remettre à niveau des
personnels d'entreprises donc ils
connaissent bien le problème alors on ne
découvre pas aujourd'hui que beaucoup
d'entre nous serait quand même assez nul
en orthographe
ce qu'on découvre c'est que la situation
s'aggraverait d'année en année et le co
vide vous avez raison les confinements
le télétravail tout ça n'a rien arrangé
alors on s'aperçoit que 76 % des
employeurs sont handicapés par les
fautes d'orthographes de leurs salariés
et au delà même par l'expression orale
ou écrite de leurs collaborateurs bref
on parle de plus en plus mal où on
parlerait de plus en plus mal du coup
ces défaillances ont des répercussions
sur la crédibilité de l'entreprise sur
son image à l'extérieur sur l'efficacité
professionnelle aussi donc sur la
réputation de l'entreprise sur sa
productivité et par conséquent sur la
performance économique et financière
alors si je caricature là je caricature
et je dirais que si on faisait moins de
fautes en aurait sans doute plus de
croissance économique plus de pouvoir
d'achat on en parle beaucoup mais moins
de chômage simplifie bien sûr mais je
suis pas loin de la vérité 93% des chefs
d'entreprise des décideurs considère que
les fautes entame la performance de leur
entreprise une faute dans un mail ça
fait tâche c'est vrai tout le monde est
très sensible aux fautes d'orthographe
surtout à celles des autres d'ailleurs
alors cette situation est tellement
préoccupante que le niveau de
l'orthographe est devenu un critère de
recrutement 86 % des recruteurs
considèrent que les fautes d'expression
écrite et orale sont rédhibitoires les
recruteurs ils font très attention on
peut dire qu'un tiers des cv passe
aujourd'hui à la corbeille pour cause de
fautes d'orthographe une faute ça passe
de fautes bonjour les dégâts on n'en
parle plus même pas 3 et comment
expliquer alors cette détérioration de
l'expression je pourrais vous dire que
la langue française est très compliquée
mais l'a toujours été donc le problème
il est ailleurs alors il est évidemment
à l'école publique ou à l'école
élémentaire puisque nombre d'élèves qui
rentrent en sixième sans savoir ni lire
ni écrire est quand même assez
inquiétant j'aurai pour ne pas dire
tragique dans certains cas entre 10 et
15 % estiment tôt c'est un vrai handicap
c'est un vrai handicap pour pour les
victimes si j'ose dire parce que ça
allait suivre toute leur vie j'ajoute
que les docteurs en pédagogie qui sont
nombreux au ministère de l'éducation
nationale ont parfois tenté d réforme de
simplification de l'orthographe on a vu
ça à partir des années 1968 on vient
encore de le voir avec la crypte
l'écriture inclusive vous savez le
résultat quand même été calamiteux dans
bien des cas plus récemment on constate
que le multiculturel aussi un peu tordu
le français dans tous les sens
l'immigration n'a pas été conditionné
par un apprentissage sérieux du français
c'est un des problèmes parmi les plus
sensibles qui seront peut-être au coeur
de la campagne présidentielle
il faudrait parler français mieux que
nous le faisons alors c'est cause là
sont culturelles sont structurels il ya
aussi peut-être d'autres raisons qui
sont liées à la modernité vous savez
autrefois on faisait moins de fautes
c'est vrai mais en réalité c'est
peut-être parce qu'il y avait des
secrétaires des assistants qui
corrigeait ses fautes aujourd'hui chacun
fait ses notes chacun fait c'est mal ça
vous qu'en france aujourd'hui on fait
plus d'un milliard de mails par jour par
jour je tente pas des textos des sms des
twitter pour travailler pour riposter
pour aimer pour rompre aussi une
relation une faute sur twitter c'est ça
ce n'est pas rien quand c'est humiliant
alors en plus on a des correcteurs
d'orthographe
fini mais qui corrige pas quoi il ajoute
des fautes à celle où vous êtes déjà
dernier point bas cette manie qu'ont
certains de glisser des termes
anglo-saxons alors qui parle très mal
anglais ne cesse de globish vous c'est
de l'anglais d'aéroport alors avec vingt
mots de vocabulaire on devrait quand
même pas faire trop de fautes graves on
peut dire que non mais grave on peut
s'en moquer moi je pense moi que c'est
très grave c'est grave parce que la
faute d'orthographe ou la faute de
grammaire c'est un marqueur d'identité
de risque de puissance aussi de
personnalités et surtout de respect de
l'autre c'est d'ailleurs en cela que
l'entreprise il fait attention celui ou
celle à qui vous écrivez et à qui vous
parlez pour qu'il vous comprennent il
vaut mieux pas faire de faute alors
c'est vrai qui vient des balles tu vous
avez raison certains considèrent que
l'orthographe c'est la forme et que ce
qui compte c'est le fond c'est le coeur
est-ce qu'ils ont raison et qu'ils n'ont
pas tort toujours est il que voltaire
puisque on parlait de lui disait lui je
crois l'orthographe c'est la science des
ânes
alors tout le monde s'est emparé de
voltaire pour justifier ses fautes mais
voltaire n'a jamais parlé des fautes
d'orthographe allemagne ils parlaient de
la façon d'écrire avec la fameuse flume
pour tremper dans l'encré il a jamais
dit que la faute d'orthographe est un
signe d'intelligence un sinon ça se
saurait non c'est l'expression c'est la
forme c'est vrai et les hommes
politiques en use et en abuse victor
hugo lui qui savait écrire disait que la
forme c'est le fond qui remonte à la
surface pour cette citation zéro faute
hein j'ai noté merci ma voiture merci
jean marc sylvestre s'était l'édito
échos de la matinale